[Musique]
voici les images d'une serre souterraine
qui se trouve à huit pieds sous terre
vous avez bien entendu à huit pieds sous
terre a été conçu par un couple de forte
civile au centre du québec lasserre se
trouve juste à côté de leur maison et ça
leur permet de récolter des fruits et
des légumes frais 12 mois par année et
pour en parler je joue à pamela gay
tremblay qui est propriétaire de cette
serre bonjour pamela bonjour alors c'est
le deuxième hiver que vous cultiver des
fruits et légumes dans cette salle
souterraine
on a vu les images beaucoup beaucoup de
verdure qu'est ce que vous cultivez au
juste mais présentement on a beaucoup ri
cho de la salade de carottes
on a beaucoup d'une rangée est en fait
de fruits exotiques des fruits exotiques
également que jean ii de fruits
exotiques et be strong la papaye des
ananas
c'est sûr que ça donne pas un groupe
comme ce qui le met sa marque donne un
petit peu quand même assez particulier
quand même faire pousser de la papaye au
québec
oh oui l'hiver d'autant plus comment
vous avez fait pour développer ce
concept parce que beaucoup de recherches
avant d'y arriver
oui ça a été une amie de recherche on
est content mais on cherchait un projet
à faire puis j'ai regardé beaucoup sur
internet le plan fond j'ai mélangé
vraiment les sans-voix lippini et la
faire chiper la voie du pénis et la fin
on peut voir en france puis la hot chips
et celles aux états unis on a fait un
beau mariage de ses deux stars l'eau
dans son os adapté au climat du québec
et pour construire la serre là j'ai lu
on a décidé petite note les recherches
et salah vous avez utilisé 359 pour
fabriquer 700 et ça sert et ça sert
finalement donc ses pneus là d'isolant
oui d'enfants aux autres qui prennent à
chaleur et qu'on croit y las vegas
chaque salle a un effet et énergie verte
un peu le cul donc est ce que c'est ce
que vous chauffer l'intérieur de la
serre non on pourrait naître des néos et
ça sera encore plus efficace mais qui
nous ont fait sur notre pc personnel
puisse se fait qu' on n'est pas encore
rendu le mais ça serait quelque chose de
juste des néons qui fait tâche alors le
faire ça serait en masse suffisante
alors
même l'hiver et à huit pieds sous terre
quelle est la température finalement
l'intérieur de la salle et la semaine
passée j'avais il ya des mères qui sont
venus la visiter puis il faisait environ
10 degrés puis il file à la jolie qui
fait très froid
c'est le lan - fac on était bien
satisfait de sulu et le coup parce que
déjà la maison évidemment vous regardez
ça on sait ce qu'est ce que moi ce que
mauvais jeu pourrait construire une ça
comme ça le coût de ce type de système
mais nous on a fait presque tout nous
mêmes les pneus ça venait du garage
familial de mon conjoint
dilitrust a été fait par nous aussi pas
qui c'est sûr le fameux jusqu'où tu es
8000 $ mais c'est sûr que quelqu'un qui
fait rien de a à z
c'est sûr que c'est sa double facilement
le prix dans une salle souterraine est
ce que les légumes les fruits ce que ça
pousse plus vite
et oui ça allait en était le sapo ce
même peut-être trop pour nous et on a
mangé le maire oui sa peau c'est
extrêmement l'été puis ça commence très
tôt si et si c'est pas nécessairement
tout le monde qui va voir à voir avec
pudeur parce qu'il faut déneiger le toit
picchu mais quand même ça va tomber en
dormance puis ça va donner des plans
très tôt puis traitant aussi c'est ce
qui est intéressant il convient de
récolte vous faites par année elle est
présentement on est à trop bien dans son
jeu par dix a mis trois fois parce que
des plans que je peux laisser l'autre
tout le temps il ya des plaques faut que
je repars décennies fait qu'à l'automne
en plein été puis printemps enfants mais
on pourrait faire plus ce souci mais
pour nous ça nous satisfait d'être en
terminant ce qu'on peut faire ce genre
de serre un peu partout au québec
ça dépend d'une saleté c'est sur les dix
villes
nous on en était chanceux affortit
villes le sont presque verre ça va
dépendre d'un aussi l'environnement du
secteur du coin en fierté parce qu'ils
ont des normes différentes ou dépendants
à la phréatiques le climat est nulle
part intéressant et ça risque de donner
peut-être des idées donc aux gens qui
nous ont entendu merci beaucoup madame
d'être appelé et surtout une très bonne
année à vous aussi revoir